A boy i've just heard yes
hold on where are you going
she wants to see him i took a
lance through the shoulder once
all of king's landing isn't known to take my
side Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is
my house of the dragon video all about the dance
of the dragons scene with alicent and rhaenyra
going at each other there's a couple different
clips that they released with the older versions
of the actresses really going at each other
in different creative ways like very creative
so there's a lot of stuff going on here i'll
explain what's going on there's a bunch of
easter eggs if you're brand new to the channel i'm
doing videos for all the episodes just like i did
for the main game of thrones series be sure
to subscribe to get them all coming with you
i should hope so let me take him i shall get no
such satisfaction from me just take my arm at
the least in the first clip alicent has demanded
to see rhaenyra's brand new baby joffrey velaryon
because of the rumors swirling all the gossip the
tea that's being poured by larry strong and all
the other people at court for that matter about
rainier's other two sons jacaeyrs and lucerys
being the bastards of harwin strong who's kind of
replaced criston cole as her protector and lover
so to speak in the whole ideas that like she's
literally just given birth so the older version of
laenor velaryon that's who this is it's the older
version of laenor i didn't expect them to switch
actors so this is kind of a surprise laenor comes
rushing in to meet her like oh i heard that you
just gave birth this is so amazing you're doing
so well you look great congratulations and he just
seems like a very supportive nice husband they
have that arrangement between the two of them and
it seems like it's been going well for them the
past 10 years like because he's gay he's been free
to pursue all of his lovers do whatever he wants
on his side of the marriage and she's been free
to have lovers do whatever she wants on her side
of the marriage and that's the problem because
she's having all these children that look nothing
like him and it seems like alicent's big thing
that she's leaning on in all the trailer footage
we've seen of her is complaining to viserys about
them being bastards like how dare she sully the
good name of the targaryen household with this
to have one child like that is a mistake f3 is
an insult she's upset at rhaenyra for a couple
different reasons not just because she wants her
son aegon ii to sit on the iron throne like it's
not all just a power play in the previous episodes
the reason why she really got mad at rhaenyra was
because she was flaunting the rules so much and
alison was beholden to the rules so much more
than anyone else she felt kind of like a slave
inside her marriage like she had fewer rights
than the commoners did clearly she did not enjoy
having sex with viserys like you could just see
her lying there like oh god please let this be
over and keep in mind that she's had a couple
more children since then so like if viserys
is getting worse and worse and worse she's
continued to have to deal with that like that side
of the marriage like you'll have to lay with him
in bed a couple different times so that you can
have these other children and the way that it's
sold to her is that it's just her duty and she
has to do it because she's supposed to do it
so in her head she's thinking if i have to follow
the rules this way why doesn't rhaenyra also have
to follow the rules why aren't there consequences
for her because at least in her eyes it feels like
rhaenyra has been getting away with this for the
past 10 years and potentially like if nobody does
anything about it one of her sons like jacarys her
oldest son could potentially become the next king
of westeros and he would be a bastard so when we
talk about alicent being the leader of team green
during the dance of the dragons really she's
more like team rules everybody needs to follow
the rules she's like hardcore about them following
the rules in the way the showrunner said that they
wanted to play rhaenyra in laenor's marriages it
was meant to be a very modern understanding like
a modern type of marriage like okay we clearly
don't love each other we're not going to have
the kind of relationship that a normal husband
and wife would have so let's just make the best
of a bad situation but alison doesn't want to have
anything to do with that she's like how dare you
flaunt the rules so that's why she's asking to
see this third child which presumably also looks
kind of like harwin strong has brown hair like her
other children so that's probably why you see that
scene of her in the trailer talking to viserys
saying how dare she do this in fact in the books
when they present the baby to her there's this
line of dialogue she has where she's basically
telling laenor keep trying eventually you'll have
one that looks like you which is like her version
of throwing as much shade at him as possible
saying i know exactly what the two of you are
doing it also seems like it doesn't help that
lara strong has been her advisor for these past
10 years and you have to imagine all the gossip
that he's been telling her about all these rumors
and most of it is probably true it seems like
what's going on with lara strong is that he's
just trying to secure as great a position as he
can with the potential heir and he's backing the
green so to speak like he thinks that aegon is
going to become the heir so that's why he's been
quote unquote helping alison all these past 10
years throwing rhaenyra under the bus every chance
he gets because if you think about it he's really
working counter to his family's best interest the
strong's because his father's already been handed
the king that's like the most powerful you can get
in the realm next to being in the royal family
in the line of succession and his brother is
rhaenyra's lover like potentially one of his
relatives could make it onto the iron throne
so wouldn't he want that so maybe he has a very
tyrion-like relationship just even darker with
his family maybe they mistreat him and that's why
he's throwing his family under the bus so to speak
so the whole joke here with her trying to make
it up the staircase inside the red keep with her
baby is like she literally just gave birth and
laenor's like what are you doing i took a lance
to the shoulder and i still don't want to have to
do something like this like he's so happy to not
have been born a woman to not have to experience
the pain of childbirth i'm glad i'm not a woman
then we have the scene of alicent and larys
strong sharing some tea there over a meal
saying that larissa's father lionel strong is no
longer giving impartial advice to king viserys
as hand of the king because it's his son harwin
strong that they think is having the affair with
rhaenyra with these bastards so viserys kind of
sounds like he doesn't want to hear any talk of
bastards like he doesn't have anything to do with
this because the way she talks about it nobody in
king's landing supports her the way that she wants
them to support her that was kind of the case in
the earlier episodes too when she was younger and
she was telling rainier it feels like nobody is
my friend here because i'm too powerful they don't
want to upset me so she really doesn't have people
to confide into the way that she did with rhaenyra
when they were good friends before they had their
big falling out and alicent is saying she wants
her father to come back to king's landing and
be the hand again even though larys also calls
her out on this saying that he as well alicent's
father would also give impartial advice so he'd
be just as bad as lara strong but the funny thing
about this is that alicent acknowledges that
and says that she doesn't care at least he would
support me basically like it sounds like nobody at
court really cares about her they're just thinking
about aegon the second like obviously there's
still the question of who the air is going to be
but it seems that because viserys is still
alive most of the realm the other lords
support rhaenyra's claim and now that she's had
a child jacaerys velaryon who could potentially
take the iron throne they're thinking more about
him than they are about aegon the second because
that was the whole idea they wanted a man on the
iron throne and at the time a couple episodes ago
there was only aegon ii so even though it sounds
like nobody supports alicent at court right now
and she kind of bemoans that it's really not all
that better for rhaenyra like the realm isn't
supporting rhaenyra they're mostly thinking about
her son eventually taking the iron throne but the
whole idea like i said is that alison thinks that
this child of hers that would take the iron throne
is a bastard and she doesn't want to have that the
funny thing about bastards taking the iron throne
is this will remind you of the blackfire rebellion
that winds up happening later in the timeline
the very similar situation winds up happening
where the ruling king at the time aegon iv
had many bastards like a robert baratheon level
of bastards most of them lived to adulthood and
he loved one of them so much that he gave them
the blackfyre sword aegon's ancestral valyrian
blade the one that you see viserys wielding during
all the episodes typically that sword was given
to the future king of westeros so you gave it
to whoever the heir was but this time aegon iv
broke tradition and instead of giving it to his
legitimate heir who was supposed to take the iron
throne he gave it to one of his bastards outside
the line of succession that particular bastard's
name was daemon he gave him the right to choose
his own name and he chose the blackfyre name
that's why they call it the blackfire rebellion
because he sort of created the blackfyre household
and eventually a bunch of people rallied to
his cause supported him and a bunch of the
other royal bastards of the time in sort of this
giant conflict that was similar to the dance of
the dragons but instead of the princess versus
the queen within the line of succession it was
the male bastard versus the male legitimate heir
they said in future seasons of house of the dragon
after they cover the dance of the dragons events
that move to a different time period so it's
totally possible that eventually we'll get the
blackfyre rebellion as a series in several years
the whole thing on the show so far is they mostly
just showing you what the power players on the
show like the really powerful people think about
everything as it's going on but really what's
happening with the rest of the commodores like the
other people in the realm their whole perception
of all the stuff that's going on is they really
just want stability in the realm that's all they
care about so they don't really care who takes the
iron throne blacks greens whoever which i think
they'll reference in later episodes like they kind
of gave you a hint about it during that daemon and
rare episode with a play like you should listen
to what the commoners think it could come back to
bite you in the ass in a big way in the future one
of the other cool details here too that you see
in the trailer is lena and daemon's daughters
pulling a dragon egg from the fire she talks
about how they're both from the blood of ancient
valyria this is meant to be an easter egg for the
targaryens customs of putting the dragon eggs in
their babies cribs they had this belief that it
would foster a stronger bond with their eventual
dragon once it hatched and if the dragon egg
wouldn't hatch it would eventually turn to stone
and it would be sort of like this really ill omen
and because we're skipping over 10 years of
history rhaenyra did that same thing with her two
first sons and what we're seeing in the trailer is
her oldest son jakirus claiming his dragon vermax
inside the dragon pit like this is taking place
inside the dragon pit so the whole idea is that
alison kept thinking that these sons were bastards
there's no way they could be dragon seas they
won't be dragon riders those dragon eggs that you
put in their cribs they won't hatch but what wound
up happening and obviously we skipped this because
the 10 year time jump is that both of those dragon
eggs wound up hatching and i talked about this
in my previous video too but even though there's
all this talk about the drama going on with the
father of her sons you have all these children
being born from these three different big power
players like daemon has children now rhaenyra has
children now and alison has even more children
so there's like a ton of kids running around
inside the royal family in every single one of
them is a dragon rider so hopefully we'll get
to see all their dragons by season two we'll see
some of them before the end of season one though
so when rhaenyra's bastard children or supposed
bastard children wind up writing dragons it just
hurts alicent's claim it makes it harder for her
to prove that they shouldn't be on the iron throne
but if you spotted any other easter eggs and
references from the new trailer that i didn't
talk about in the video just write them below in
the comments my full episode 6 easter eggs video
will post on sunday after they release it everyone
click here for my full episode 6 trailer video
with a whole bunch of brand new footage and click
here for all my house of the dragon episode videos
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!